Just got off the phone with a friend of
mine who's competing in a fitness thing
and she didn't win this fitness thing
and she looked at the winner of that
fitness thing and was like, I don't know
if I would want to look that way in
order to win this prize. And so it
created a really good conversation that
I think I'll share with you, which is
that if you play stupid games, you win
stupid prizes.
I'll say that again. Play dumb games,
win dumb prizes. And so I think one of
the most tragic things that can happen
to us throughout our lives is that we
work very hard, we sacrifice a lot, we
get to the top of the podium and we work
and win a trophy and then we realize
this is not where we want to be and this
is not what I wanted to win.
And this game really didn't matter.
And it was only to win in the eyes of
people that I don't care about. And so
I think one of the most interesting ways
of thinking about life is through game
design, right? Like we are all playing
games. Many of us are involved in
multiple games, you know, at the same
time. We have our business game, we have
our fitness game, we have our our
relationship games. Like there's these
games that are we're we're involved in
many of them. Some are finite, some are
infinite. Um
but this particular thing, let's just
say your career, your interests, um
understanding
who the person is who determines who who
wins. And so this in this particular
instance,
um
I said to her,
number one,
you are not the one who's defining the
physique that is going to win this
competition.
Someone else is.
Number two,
it's not super clearly defined um and
even if it were,
would you want it? Now, the way that
they do this in the aesthetic shows for
for bodybuilding and things like that is
they try and signal to the whole sport
what they want by who they select as the
winners. Seems kind of obvious. Um it's
a little bit backwards, but that's kind
of how it works. Like uh this person
won, by the way, that's what we're
looking for. It's like, well no
the game the game's already over, right?
But that's kind of how it works. And so
for the next competition, people try to
look more like that one and then
somebody else wins and if they want
shift a look over time of what they're
looking for, then they start moving what
they want the champions to be. All
right. But, the point is this is that in
order for her to look that way, she
would have to make sacrifices in her
life that I don't think um are worth
making.
Rather, they would be too costly to the
other parts of her life.
And so, in in talking about this, it was
just such a really interesting um
notion compared as as you compare it to
how people live their lives. And I think
so many people live mediocre lives
because they play games that other
people design that even if they did win,
they wouldn't want the prize.
And so, if you're if you're playing a
game right now and you're losing,
you have to ask yourself,
is this a game that when I take it to
the natural tree, am I actually want to
win?
And what is the price of winning?
And what is the benefit of winning?
And
in the and I I think that the fittest in
the aesthetic world is kind of
interesting because like many people who
are in that world
believe that if they somehow become a
pro or win a certain number of shows or
become top on Olympia or whatever, that
that's somehow going to make them
successful in business. And it it really
couldn't be further from the truth.
There's tons of broke fitness people. Um
and all you have to do is look at past
champions and some of them who didn't
learn business just are are are broke,
right? They stop getting their their
moment in the sun, they get their
sponsorship go away, and then they're
back to zero again. And so, what I think
happens more often is that they have a
way that they kind of understand how to
do. They know how to increase their reps
and and eat and do cardio and all that
stuff, improve over time. And so,
because they understand how to improve
at this, they choose not to be a
beginner in other places,
like business, like marketing, like
sales, etc.
And so, they
without conscious knowledge, end up
dedicating 5, 10 plus years of their
life and taking years off their life
from a health perspective, because the
sport, especially at the highest levels,
is really tough on you.
To
not actually get what they want, because
they never played it out, because it was
emotionally uncomfortable to think about
what it would be like to suck at
something new.
And so, I think it's a really good
allegory for how a lot of us, myself
included, right? We live our lives where
it's like, what thing am I doing
what game am I playing that I am
that I'm only playing because I'm
comfortable in the game, and I
understand the variables and the
players, and I know how to win.
And so, just because you know how to
win,
doesn't mean you should win, and it
doesn't mean the game is worth playing.
And
there might be a different or parallel
or superior game
that
if it were played, would result in the
thing that I actually want. And so, I
saw this really interesting interview, I
can't remember who who who it was, um
but it was David Sacks on the Founders
Podcast, and there was this this
soundbite that that I thought was
really, really intelligent, which was
the the business that plays the most
dominant game wins. So, he gives this
example between MySpace and Facebook. He
said, so,
MySpace was playing the get the most
users game.
Facebook was playing the monthly active
And monthly active users game, that
metric that they optimized around was
the dominant game, because it doesn't
matter how many people opt in to
something, what matters is who's
actually using it. Right? It was a
dominant game, and if you accomplish
this one, all the things that come from
the inferior game, the spoils of that,
would go to the the person who played a
a superior game. And so, this is
conceptually the same idea of a um
a finite versus an infinite game. Right?
Now, that's both of those are are I
guess technically
infinite games, I guess you can keep
going, right? Um
but from a finite versus infinite
perspective,
a finite game would be like baseball,
there's a know, you know, known rules,
known players,
and then there's a degree upon outcome
at the end, right? Whereas in finite
game, there are known and unknown
players, there are no rules, and the
point of the game is to keep the game
going. And so, whenever you have a
infinite game player who's going against
a finite player, the infinite player
always wins. So, when the US went to
Vietnam, for example, we had a finite
frame, we had to we tried to win the
war, but the Vietnam just the goal for
them was to keep the war going until
eventually we
stopped, and that's exactly what
happened, right? We just like kind of
like gave up and just went home.
Again, I'm not trying to this is not a
political thing, but the point is is
that
dominant games, playing dominant games
allows you to win better prizes.
And so, right now
there are games that you are playing
either consciously or unconsciously, and
I think the question to ask is
one, am I the person who designed this
game? Two,
if I didn't design the game, do I want
the prize that comes with it? Three, am
I willing to pay the price or the
sacrifice required to win at this game,
and is that globally worth it? So, think
about the difference in global and in
local. Like, locally I can win this
game, but globally I might lose my life,
right? You don't want to have a local
thing come at the cost of a global
thing.
Hopefully that's tracking. Subset,
superset.
And so,
this is
yet another Sunday thought
from a conversation this week that I
thought was really important, and so I
said, "If I were you, if you enjoy
competing and you like having the
target, then control the controllables.
Look the way you want to look,
prep the way that you know that you
should prep, and then go in and do your
best, and you judge yourself based on
how well you think you did based on what
you wanted. If you think you look the
best on stage by your standards, then
congratulations, you won. And you don't
need the $10 trophy.
And if you want to use this to make more
money, then this is obviously a terrible
way of making more money. There's a
hundred other ways that you can make
more money besides this.
And so, that was That was what I told
her, and that's what I'll tell you,
which is
play your own games of your own design,
where if you were to win, you would be
happy with the W, and the price that it
came at was one that you were willing to
pay.
Ow.
Real quick, I'm going to show you the
exact 10-stage roadmap from zero to 100
million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish, I've now done multiple
times, and so I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages as
head count increases that you need to
get through, and I broke each of these
down by eight different functions of the
business, what the constraint feels
like, like what are the symptoms of it
when you're going through it, and then
what steps we actually took to graduate.
And we've done this across software,
physical products,
service businesses, brick and mortar,
all of this, and it works. And it's my
gift to you, it's absolutely free. And
so, the link's in the description, but
you just go acquisition.com/roadmap,
just enter your info, and it'll spit it
right back to you, all free.